خلف الدخان سمع مصر السبت بعد اشتعال
النيران في مقر اتحاد كره القدم ونادي
للشرطه
وقد حاول رجال الاطفاء والسنه اللهب على
الارض بينما انطلقت الطائرات المروحيه
لاخمادها من السماء ولكن بالنسبه للكثير
من هذه المباني لم تتمكن الجهات المسؤوله
من السيطره على جميع الحرائق ما تسبب في
اضرار بالغه داخلها ويلقي المسؤولون هنا
باللوم على مشجعين النادي الاهلي بالتسبب
في هذه الحرائق فقد شهد السبت تجمع نحو
الف من المشجعين امام مقر النادي رافعين
شعارات تقول لن ننساكم ابدا في اشاره الى
اثنين وسبعين قتيلا من مشجعي النادي سقطوا
في ملعب بورسعيد العام الماضي وقد اتى
هؤلاء المشجعون الى هنا لسماع الحكم فيما
عرف بمجزره بورسعيد
وبعد تاكيد الحكم باعدام واحد وعشرين شخصا
بدات الاحتفالات
غير انها ما لبثت ان تحولت الى سخط وغضب
بعد تبرئه ثمانيه وعشرين شخصا اخرين من
بينهم سبعه من رجال الشرطه
الحكم على
الداخليه لم المسؤولين عن فتح الابواب
واصل نواب ومدير الامن والدينا دي كلها من
الكاشف ياخذوا وخمسمائه طبعا مع الاستئناف
والحقت بها الحالي
والاردن
اليوم يكون لها الشهداء المشاكل حاجه
بسيطه يعني حقيقه
وتوعد شباب الاولتراس بالشارع وهم الذين
لم يكنوا وعودهم في ميدان التحرير اندلعت
اشتباكات عنيفه بين مشجعين النادي والشرطه
غير ان الشرطه من وجهه نظرهم ايضا يرون
بان هم ضحايا لما يجري
فهم يشتكون من ضعف تسليحهم وتدريبهم
للتعامل مع مثل هذه المواقف كما ان كل
اللوم يقع دائما على عاتقهم في حال مقتل
اي من المتظاهرين
من اجل ذلك اعتصم الكثير من افراد الشرطه
في مدن مختلفه مطالبين برحيل وزير
الداخليه
المتظاهرون والشرطه الطرفان اخوان معركه
مع الاخر وكل منهما يحمل شعورا بالخيانه
من قبل منهم في منصبا على